toxic chemical spills are no big deal
for America's Transportation secretary
health concerns are growing in Ohio
despite assurances that everything is
safe Pete Buddha judge giving his first
media interview on the disaster and
downplayed what happened
Rail City is something that uh that has
evolved a lot over the years but there's
clearly more that needs to be done
because while this uh horrible situation
has gotten a particularly high amount of
attention there are roughly 1 000 cases
a year of a train derailing
also said that he hoped he hoped to get
to know some of the folks who are
impacted by this but claims the reason
he hasn't visited is that he wants to
respect the investigation East Palestine
mayor Trent Conaway thinks feet staying
away is a good idea
it was just a dog and pony show uh you
know they've they've sort of let us hang
hang out the dry here as far as mayor
Pete as people like to call him I would
rather he just stay away uh he is this
going to cause a circus and unless he's
going to bring a shovel and shovel some
dirt and get rid of this contaminated
soil that's that's the only reason he
would need to come to this town we have
a town of 4 700 people that are scared
want answers and you know as far as the
federal government's concerned I you
know I I don't have much faith in them
they were late to the dances I like to
say and you know uh our people deserve
better
Ohio's governor and the Biden EPA
continued to say that the town's
drinking water shows no sign of
contamination and they want residents to
trust them
if people want to go different places
and want more assurances or want time to
pass a little bit they have a right to
do that but for those who can't I am
asking that they trust the government
and that's hard we know that there is a
lack of trust which is why the state and
the federal government have pledged to
be very transparent
but locals are having a hard time
trusting the government when they can
still smell toxins in the air and they
can see a chemical rainbow in the creeks
it is a really scary situation and we
are very concerned as a community we
don't know what to believe at this point
we have so many people telling us so
many different things the amount of
chemicals cancer-causing chemicals that
were released and what were left to deal
with we need a little bit of guidance
here my throat's been burning I've had a
horrible cough sneezing just congestion
my eyes have burned it's it's scary
okay uh Shannon I'm going to start with
you
um you know since this happened on
February the 3rd uh FEMA was nowhere to
be found the federal government was
nowhere to be founded in fact the
federal government is now telling
Governor dewine that they're not
eligible uh for FEMA assistance and yet
this EP administrator uh Michael Reagan
I think his name is is saying oh
everything's safe trust the government
could he have thought of a dumber thing
to say because clearly these people feel
that they've been forgotten they
actually have hundreds in this town of
less than 5 000 people who show up for
meeting Buddha Jets is nowhere to be
found and neither is uh Norfolk Southern
and FEMA's not there what's going on
there I think that when you tell people
to trust the government the instinct is
no thank you all of the recent polling
shows that trust in institutions is just
completely eroding Pew had one in recent
months that said only 20 percent of
Americans say they trust the government
to do the right thing most of the time
so these people are very distrustful and
they should be because this is we're two
weeks into this now and a lot of people
have never heard of it or they've only
heard it until the last day or two
there's plenty of blame to go around
here but when you have secretary Buddha
judge saying things like oh there are a
thousand derailments or more every year
well you could say to people there are
thousands of crimes a year but when it
hits you and your family in your
neighborhood
um that's real world and these people
most of them cannot just go stay in a
hotel or go to their second home they
don't have one their surviving moment to
moment and I'm sure they would love for
a lot of people to show up and say this
is how we are going to step in and help
you you know Jesse Pete put a judge
saying there are there are many Trail
deraments uh derailments a year ignores
the fact that there were toxic chemicals
final chloride that's mixed with wheat
Seminola and frozen vegetables nobody's
talking about the fact that there is
food on board with hazardous waste and
this guy Buddha judge is so clueless
he's like oh this is just a derailment
no it's not that's why he didn't get a
lot of votes in the primary remember
black voters never even gave the guy a
look one of the main reasons is because
the guy has got no heart he's got no
passions he has no empathy he's a
technocrat he's a McKinsey guy that just
sees numbers he doesn't see people what
you want to do is you want to go there
you want to embrace the town literally
embrace them with your arms but he can't
be bothered to do that he says he wants
to respect the investigation by not
going this would be like if Jesse Jr
just spilled everything all over the
floor and my wife Emma says you know
Jesse can you come help clean up and say
sorry I'm going to stay over here and
respect the cleanup that doesn't make
any sense but has it happened Jesse
you know what and I was treated like
mayor Pete after I use that line
I'm not even gonna make a second joke
you actually you have to be there and
and life is about showing up also the
New York Times is now coming out and
Blasting conservative commentators for
saying that they're speculating too much
and that they're showing distrust of the
government
oh wait a second the New York Times is
speculating that we're all going to die
in 10 years if we stop we don't stop
using plastic straws sorry I'm
speculating that there was a toxic train
wreck that might give everybody cancer
and sorry that I don't trust the
government the government's lied to you
Barack Obama
the Messiah said the drinking water in
Flint Michigan was clean and so did it
so did his EPA so now all of a sudden
they're going to say it again sorry
trust but verify yeah but in the same
EPA from Flint Michigan and and also
from 9 11 and and Jessica you can speak
to this better than anyone given the
laws that you've suffered you know we
now have Senator JD Vance saying that uh
when he puts a stick in the in the in a
creek it whips up a chemical rainbow and
that there are dead fish there are no
birds flying in the sky and then you've
got dewine and uh the EPA and uh
everyone criticizing saying the the
water is safe no it's not yeah it's
evident quite clearly not safe and you'd
be out of your mind frankly or with very
little options if you're going to be
drinking the drinking water and I know
that they're delivering a lot of bottled
water but we talked about this yesterday
I think you need to get everyone out of
there until you can be completely sure
there's no problem where your Creeks
don't have oil spills in it and you're
not getting an iridescent uh showing
there governor dewine was on with Fox
and Friends this morning and uh Brian
and Ainsley really held his feet to the
fire they did Brian got really angry and
it's been two weeks right so the story
has really only kind of I'd say the last
two or three days taken hold of a
national audience it was obviously an
incredibly big deal in Ohio and we
weren't paying enough attention to it
and people are frightened I saw a
grandfather who takes care of his three
granddaughters who was interviewed last
night the kids were covered in rashes
until a couple of days ago showed all of
the pictures of it that's irrefutable
evidence that something is not right I
is it going to cause cancer I have
absolutely no idea but you know that you
don't want to be there and to people to
judge's point about the Thousand
derailments I do think it is important
to talk about this as a safety problem
it became a big issue in 2014 there was
a crash similar to this in New Jersey
where there were toxic chemicals on
board and the Obama Administration put
forward a new role that they wanted to
get past for regulating trains to
upgrade the brake systems if it had a
petroleum on it as well as toxic
chemicals and that got watered down to
remove the toxic chemicals part of it
which I think is the most important
component and then Norfolk Southern and
other railroad industry honchos and you
talked about this year yesterday Jesse
lobbied governments and in 2017 during
the Trump administration were able to
pull back a rule that would have
upgraded Civil War era brake systems
Civil War era well that was Congress
that that actually I said that during
the Trump years though that's relevant
because everyone yeah
okay Trump is perfect the point is the
brake systems need to be upgraded we
know that this is a problem it has been
a problem for some time and this will
continue to happen I think that's what
Pete Buda judge was talking about all
right Tom I'm gonna wrap it up I got an
idea how about from now on uh every
train has to have one car filled with
toxic masculinity then when there's a
spill
Democrats will pay attention right uh
what about the irony of this this town
first of all I love this town they have
a very Duck Dynasty Vibe I want to hang
there when everything's all cleaned up I
want to hang with these people shoot
some guns things like that but the these
are the people these blue-collar people
were told they couldn't leave their
house because of a virus they had to
mask their children because of a virus
now they're saying hey drink the shiny
water everything's okay I mean they have
flipped completely what happened to uh
an abundance of caution they're telling
everyone you know everything's fine when
it's obviously not fine it's almost like
it's unbelievable the the flipping of
risk assessment right yeah yeah well
we'll see what happens but I really want
to know who's who's ordering and who's
doing the testing as you spoke about
yesterday hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else